- We're at my shop.
And it's a balmy 36 degrees in
Jamesville.
Come on in.
This is my forge.
I got this from a buddy of
mine.
If you ever need anything and
you tell him,
he can usually find it.
Got my anvil set up here.
And it's a bit small but
a Farrier anvil,
and it works fine for what I
today typically.
A little welder that I use for
a lot of different things,
my metal sculptures, any kind
of builds.
- My home forge is in central
New Jersey,
town of Edison.
As you can see from behind me,
it's snowing.
And that is fantastic.
At least I'm warm inside my
shed.
♪ ♪
I don't know anything about the
cameramen, though.
They're--they're gonna be cold
standing on the outside looking
in.
[metal clanging]
♪ ♪
- For the most part, this is
where I do the jewelry
and my leather work,
which includes saddle repair,
tack, et cetera.
I make chaps.
You name it.
This messy table right here is
typically what I'll do
any of my casting or soldering.
I started doing it maybe ten
years ago
as opposed to sending the
castings out.
It works great.
This bench over here is kind of
where I do all the fine work,
anything from sizing a ring,
stone setting.
Anything kind of small and
finicky I do at this bench.
And really, that's--that's
about it.
It's a relaxing place.
I enjoy it.
- So I'm almost done grinding.
I haven't put an edge on it
yet.
But I want to test the heat
treat by beating the crap
out of something, so I'm just
gonna beat up
one of these 8x8s that I have
right here.
♪ ♪
Back edge still straight.
Nice.
Looks like it should survive.
That is unless they throw
something really dumb at it,
like chop through at 2-inch
steel rod.